bonjour
je suis explorateurs ça marche bien avec
les filles au général mais surtout ça
permet quelque chose d'extraordinaire
c'est de rencontrer des terrains des
territoires des lieux assez
extraordinaire et qu'on soit en groupe
conçoit seul de découvrir de pénétrer
des lieux qui nous touche
particulièrement il ya une forme d'
absolue dans la notion de découvrir des
territoires nouveaux et cette forme
d'absolu je crois qu'elle est
fondamentalement humaine on est un
humain seul ou en petit groupe
dans ce territoire qui nous dépasse
totalement vous devrez essayer de
comprendre mais qu'on comprend jamais
totalement tellement il est immense et
on essaye de s'y imprégner de le
comprendre de savoir comment il vit est
de savoir comment nous on vit à
l'intérieur de lui en faisant ça notre
métier notre travail c'est de faire
avancer la connaissance de l'humanité
et quand on fait ce travail dans des
lieux comme ça eh ben on se prend un peu
pour superman quand même et puis après
on regarde la photo de trois semaines
d'expédition et on se dit qu'on est un
peu plus même que super quand même mais
enfin surtout quand je regarde cette
photo je repense à ce que je suis en
train de regarder à savoir mon camp
après une belle tempête qui a tout
balayé tout est trempé j'essaie de faire
sécher mon matériel et que je regarde ce
matériel je me rends compte que ben non
en fait je suis pas seul du tout oui ok
je suis sur le terrain tout seul mais
pour que je puisse y être il y a des
dizaines des centaines des milliers de
personnes qui ont oeuvré à des moments
pour que je puisse être là parce que
chaque équipement que j'ai avec moi
représente un outil technologique
extraordinaire que des humains femmes
hommes ont passé des jours des années
des décennies parfois développé pour
rendre possible cette exploration et
c'est encore plus vrai évidemment pour
tout ce qui est aujourd'hui
communication je peux communiquer
envoyer des données scientifiques
directement je peux savoir où je suis
grâce à un gps est alors en parle même
pas des lieux
or atmosphère si je vais soul soul aussi
je veux aller dans l'espace
j'ai besoin d'outils qui sont tellement
technologique que je ne suis plus
capable évidemment des développer tout
seul et que j'ai besoin d'avoir
l'ensemble de l'humain qui travaillent
avec moi avec nous pour pouvoir
continuer leurs oeuvres à savoir
explorer notre monde exploré ce que nous
sommes mais c'est vrai qu'au travers des
années des siècles on a souvent eu
l'idée que la technologie à led et pas
s'il lui manque finalement l'huma
n'étaient plus nécessaires à
l'exploration et ça c'est arrivé très
régulièrement et c'est vrai que quand on
voit cette image du nombre de satellites
qui entoure notre planète qui scrute
notre planète
vasic effectivement peut-être que
l'humain et peut rester assis et que le
satellite va trier faire le boulot à la
place quoi essayer de voir dans une
grotte avec un satellite sous les arbres
ou je ne sais où et c'est surtout de
vous dire que cette idée là que l'on
connaît tous que l'on sait tout elle est
pas nouvelle quand collomb veut partir
pour son premier voyage en 1492
il va avoir en 1490 les différents rois
d'europe et on lui répond à ces à
l'arrière le mot mais mon pauvre ami
on sait déjà très bien ce qu'il ya
au-delà des mers il n'y a rien on
connaissait même pas un quart de la
planète
cette expédition ne sert à rien elle est
trop chère et trop risqué on ne peut pas
la financer voilà ce qu'on répond à
colombes 1490 je crois qu'on peut se
poser cette question aussi aujourd'hui
on a tendance à penser que nos
satellites nos systèmes nous donne la
solution alors qu'ils ne sont que des
outils comme l'ont été l'astrolabe comme
l'on est à la boussole comme l'ont été
le sextant qui déjà chacun d'eux a posé
la question est ce que finalement
donnant ses outils à des humains on va
pas aller trop loin
et ben non prenons ces outils et
travaillons avec mais c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui les explorateurs de
l'univers c'est des robots c'est
curiosity sur mars
ses filets rosetta est d'ailleurs la
nasa est en train de préparer les futurs
explorateurs ce superbe robot entre
autres que je suis pas sûr de beaucoup
aimer parce qu'ils me prendre mon job
mais que j'aime toujours mieux que
celui-là qui est une autre vision de la
technologie que terminator nous a amenés
sur le chemin de demain qui serait un
robot qui aurait pris notre travail avec
une intelligence artificielle
extraordinaire intelligence artificielle
d'ailleurs qui aujourd'hui est remis en
question parce qu'en 2016
on a pour la première fois un ordinateur
qui a battu le meilleur joueur de jeu de
go vous savez que le jeu de go c'était
le jeu considéré comme le plus complexe
et le plus versatile parce que tellement
ya deux possibilités on pensait que ça
ne pouvait pas être battu par un
ordinateur à bienne l'a fait
l'ordinateur et ça remet plein de choses
en cause mais non ça remet rien en cause
en fait parce que ça reste un jeu et que
nous on vit des vies et que ces vielles
sont bien plus complexes que tout ce
qu'on peut imaginer
et que je pense sincèrement
qu'aujourd'hui on doit pas forcément
craindre à cette idée que l'humain de
demain ne sera qu'un super système ultra
technologique nano travailler pour
pouvoir dépasser des ordinateurs pour
dépasser d'ordinateurs qu'on aura nos
même créé la question n'est pas là je
crois qu'on doit se reposer la question
tout simplement de ce qu'on veut nous
pour ce que nous sommes de ceux que nous
avons été et ce qui est intéressant
c'est que l'humain
depuis qu'il est espèces depuis qu'il
existe depuis qu'il évolue
il a toujours cherché à aller plus loin
à comprendre à explorer à découvrir
cette curiosité là elle est ce que nous
sommes en tant qu'espèce on n'est pas la
seule espèce comme ça et c'est en tout
cas ce qui nous définit nous en tant
qu'espèce est une chose que
l'exploration doit porter rae a porté en
tout cas ce site wikio stagne au monde
oui
lorsque lesdits prononce ce discours
nous avons choisi d'aller sur la lune on
est capable de renvoyer un engin spatial
à 20 km de la terre à peine en disant on
va passer sur la capacité de déposer un
humain sur la dune quand on regarde
cette image on voit cette capsule
lunaire extraordinaire de technologie ce
qu'on peut imaginer ce que ça représente
d'avoir créé et ceci tout ça pour une
chose pour une chose pour mettre un
humain capable de faire son premier pas
sur la lune et c'est ça aussi qu'on a
besoin
la technologie n est pas là pour nous
remplacer
hélas là pour nous aider à continuer à
rêver parce que finalement c'est ça que
nous sommes aussi des êtres de rêve et
d'espoir des aides qui peuvent croire en
demain et ça c'est quelque chose
d'important et l'exploration d'un autre
donnée aussi intéressante à tous ceux
qui vous diront un jour parce que vous
entendrez ça un jour moi je l'entends
tous les jours dans mon métier on sait
déjà tout à quoi ça sert de continuer
d'explorer et bien imaginez un bébé qui
vient de naître
ce petit bébé ce prématurée qui est dans
une couveuse aussi un outil
technologique extraordinaire
c'est ce qui nous est le plus proche une
femme pendant neuf mois
la porter en elle puis à accoucher et
ben ce bébé doit sans ventre il a des
centaines de bactéries on n'en connaît
pas la moitié
ce qui nous est le plus proche le plus
intime
on ne connaît pas complètement on savait
pas encore ya quelques années qui
avaient des neurones de l'estomac dans
le coeur bref on est loin très très loin
de tout savoir et c'est vrai pour tous
les domaines et c'est vrai aussi
qu'aujourd'hui
l'ultra technologie de nous questionner
sur notre société sous notre sociabilité
sur ce que nous sommes en tant qu'humain
parce que ce groupe humain
extraordinaire qui vit sur une terre qui
est en changement
personne va le contester cette terre qui
évolue
humains qui sont aujourd'hui de quelques
milliards 7 milliards 8 milliard il ya
12 9 milliards
on doit non plus simplement se poser la
question de ce que la technologie nous
apporte
on doit se poser la question de comment
nous humains chacun entre nous on doit
cesser d'avoir peur des autres on doit
cesser de se combattre les uns les
autres
mais comment l'innovation va nous
permettre de vivre ensemble et ça c'est
aussi un rôle que nous avons nous
explorateurs que nous avons tous parce
que nous sommes tous des explorateurs à
savoir de continuer de questionner notre
humanité notre humain est ce que nous
sommes
alors nous avec un groupe de travail en
a choisi de questionner une chose c'est
notre cerveau parce que là encore c'est
un domaine on connait pas grand chose
il ya quelques années on a complètement
mis en cause des choses on continue de
les remettre en cause et pour
questionner notre cerveau on va sortir
de laboratoire et on va se servir
justement des explorateurs pour aller
sur le terrain c'est le human
adaptabilité insitu project qui présente
adaptation d'ailleurs arts et métiers en
est un des partenaires avec l'école
normale supérieure avec différents
laboratoires où on va amener des humains
dans l'es4 milieu des plus extrêmes de
la planète des plus complexes haut
niveau versatilité pour essayer de voir
comment nous humains on est capable de
modifier ou de faire évoluer notre
cerveau dans une situation complexe de
crise de changement d'adaptation et
c'est ça qu'on est en train de chercher
je vais le faire seul cette année dans
les quatre milieux des plus extrêmes de
la planète qu'on voit défiler derrière
derrière moi et puis l'année prochaine
on part avec 20 personnes
vingt personnes qu'on va choisir 25 40
ans qui vont partir avec moi qui leur ai
aucune expérience préalable
vous êtes tous les bienvenus d'ailleurs
je suis sûr que vous avez très envie de
partir eh bien ces personnes on va
travailler ensemble pour construire non
pas une nouvelle technologie une
nouvelle connaissance sur ce que nous
sommes nous un humain dans un monde qui
évolue et dans lequel on va devoir
s'adapter parce que oui la technologie
va nous y aider
mais nous devons aussi trouver notre
propre système adaptatif et c'est là que
c'est important
c'est là que nous devons oublier l'idée
que nous sommes en lutte où on combat de
la technologie contre l'humain nom que
nous devons travailler ensemble
technology innovation vous d'ailleurs
qui est la jeune génération qui est ce
qu'ils allaient créer le monde de demain
de nouveaux innovation nouveau
technologie de vos industries et bien
vous avez ce rôle extraordinairement
puissant que de redonner le goût de
l'avenir à l'humain dans sa manière
d'être social et non pas seulement
technologique
aujourd'hui il ya des choses
extraordinaires qui se font ou les
explorateurs et les innovateurs
travaillent ensemble comme planet solar
qui était le premier bateau solaire à
faire le tour du monde
cela en plus tout le monde en a entendu
parler cet avion qui est en train de
faire le tour du monde
ce sont des petites choses des petits
pas mais qui sont extraordinaires parce
qu'il donne en allant un espoir une
envie exactement quand kennedy qui dit
on va aller sur la lune
aujourd'hui on va pouvoir se déplacer
sans utiliser autre chose que l'énergie
solaire c'est un sacré défi et c'est le
col le conjointement d'explorateurs et
d'innovateurs qui permet de le faire et
ça c'est très important mais on a autre
chose pendant qu'on doit faire
aujourd'hui on doit cesser de se dire
que la technologie va tout résoudre
et nous et humain si la technologie à
son rôle que de faire évoluer les choses
nous devons aussi retrouvé le goût du
risque le goût du risque
vous savez cette idée que ce bébé
prématuré qui a grandi de quelques mois
et qui commence et c'est faire ses
premiers pas il va essayer de se lever
qui va se casser la gueule une tête se
faire un peu mal à la jambe au bras à la
tête mais il va réessayer
il va rester y est vous voyez beaucoup
vous du maquis rampe par terre dans la
rue parce qu'ils n'ont pas osé réessayer
non ça n'existe pas tomber tomber c'est
nous donner la possibilité de nous
relever et si demain on mettait un
système en place par un système
gravitationnelle génial qui empêche à
l'enfant de tomber quand il va essayer
de marcher alors là oui on commence à
avoir des problèmes sur notre humanité
parce que nous avons besoin de choir
pour oser nous relever parce que nous
avons besoin de croire que nous sommes
toujours capables d'avancer même lorsque
les choses ne vont plus bien et c'est
parce que nous sommes tombés la première
fois que nous avons aussi une marche et
que nous pouvons continuer d'y croire
une dernière chose qu'on va devoir
retrouver aussi pour que demain on pu
cesser de construire un monde qui soit
plus sociale plus humain plus
personnelle à chacun d'entre nous c'est
l'émerveillement
quand on voit cette planète sur laquelle
on est invité à vivre depuis quelques
millénaires on peut espérer être encore
invité à y vivre quelques millénaires de
plus sa beauté son extraordinaire
diversité
comment est-ce qu'on peut ne pas s'en
émerveiller et puis il faut regarder
cette planète cette pluie où il ya
toutes ces lumières éclairé qui chacune
est un petit bijou de technologie parce
que on doit aussi s'émerveiller de
chaque ampoule qui s'allume pas ce que
vous imaginez ce que c'est qu'une
ampoule qui s'allument
ça fait quelques secondes dans notre
humanité qu on est capable d'allumer une
ampoule si extraordinaire et puis chaque
ampoule jacques lumière c'est une maison
dans cette maison il ya des humains
et quand ils rentrent le soir ils se
racontent des histoires racontent leur
journée sera construisant de manger au
petit déjeuner comme sur facebook
aujourd'hui le café qu'on a bu le moment
qu'on a vécu ça c'était vrai avant
avant il y avait pas de lumière mais on
faisait ça de la nuit qu on a créé un
feu on a partagé autour du feu puis on a
allumé la première ampoule on a commencé
à raconter nos histoires sous une
ampoule à l'époque c'était des sales
filaments c'est devenu des lettres
demain ce sera du graphène
ouais mais l'histoire reste la même les
humains ils se racontent des histoires
que ce soit au travers de facebook ou en
réalité c'est parle d'eux leur vie de
contes de légendes d'histoires d'hommes
tout simplement
alors je sais pas ce que sera vraiment
l'exploration de demain et l'avenir de
l'humain dans cette exploration et de
notre avis avenir de la planète
je suis sûr d'une chose c'est que si
vous six mois si nous tous
en garde notre capacité d'émerveillement
face à chaque chose qui constitue notre
monde à chaque élément technologique
créé à chaque humain qui embrasse un
autre humain si on peut garder cet
émerveillement
ce goût du risque et cette envie
d'avancer
alors je suis persuadé qu'on pourra
continuer de croire en demain et c'est
ce que nous allons faire tous ensemble
merci